[Musique]
hajnal string dit soudas a loué ses
promesses
je t'avais premier défi plus de magie et
d'émerveillement regarde mes deux filles
j'ai absolument tout ce que ce désir ici
si vous pouviez faire apparaître quelque
chose comme par magie
ce serait quoi
un lion un éléphant oisiens haut comme
l'allié fille je crois que j'ai une idée
imaginez un endroit où vous découvrirez
un univers inconnu
ce projet est quelque peu bizarre le
public est fasciné par l'insolite et le
macabre je vous présente le célèbre
géant irlandais je suis pas irlandais on
va travailler votre accent
les gens vont se moquer de nous
ils se moquent déjà alors autant qu'on
soit payé pour ça
il en veut toujours plus je ne fais pas
ça pour moi
les écoutez pas c'est leur échappe
encore mais ils finiront par comprendre
[Musique]
vous mettez des gens de toutes sortes
sur scène avec vous sur un pied
d'égalité
de plus en plus de gens manifestent
contre nous
ah non tu met en danger tout ce que tu
as construit comment vois tu que je les
construis tu n'as pas besoin d'être aimé
de la terre entière
seulement de quelques gens bien
tu n'as pas honte de toi père le monde
change et je refuse de vivre dans le
vôtre
nous a mis dans la lumière qui nous a
offert et vous ré famille s
on ne peut pas faire la différence en
faisant comme tout le monde
[Applaudissements]